charlie hebdo fête cette année ses 40
ans ou plus exactement ses 35 ans
puisqu'il fut en fait le petit frère
survivant de hara kiri
l'hebdomadaire qui sans vouloir s'était
autodétruit avec ce titre bal tragique à
colombey un mort c'était après la mort
du général de gaulle mais aussi un
solide night club où plusieurs centaines
de jeunes avaient péri interdit hara
kiri réapparaissez avec un nouveau titre
charlie hebdo qui devient entre autres
le journal officiel de la campagne de
coluche en 1980 un rappel historique
avec nicolas le marigny si tu te
rappelles chef et buffet bontems pas du
tout ce point difficile de se rappeler
de tous les noms ça fait tant d'années
que wolinski kavanagh et les autres
martyrise l'actualité dans charlie hebdo
style blues de st quel talent ça c'est
qu'à bull l'histoire commence quand
l'ancêtre de charlie hara kiri est
interdite à cause de ce titre sur la
mort du général de gaulle ya pas de
différence y ont droit aux insultes
volent en prénationale d'un parent jura
chef de l'état pourtant hara kiri est
mort vive charlie hebdo sous un nouveau
nom
la bande de copains poursuit ses oeuvres
bête et méchante dans les années 70 soit
l'hebdomadaire tire alors à 150 mille
exemplaires ce qui est important c'était
encore plus que le journal les gens qui
le faisait on sait mais bien on sait
mais beaucoup et on s'admire est les uns
les autres
l'équipe est solidaire enchaîne les
procès et ne tolère aucun obstacle à son
insolence deneux président chez ses
passions l'offre est maintenant en 1981
charlie hebdo dépose le bilan
avant de reparaître en 1991 sous
l'impulsion de philippe val de savoir ce
que va dire ça passe il faut écouter ce
que dit chirac parce qu'on sait qu'il va
dire le contraire
si si chirac dit je me gratte que tu
sarkozy va dire je me gratte le nez
les anciens sont toujours là et depuis
13 ans de nouveaux dessinateurs prenne
la relève
c'est de ce joint l'on peut faire des
dessins franchement satirique
donc voilà donc c'est un espace qui rare
sans pitié pour les hommes politiques et
les puissants en général charlie hebdo
rit de tout et de tous c'est ça l'esprit
charny